zane malik is going on the defense after
being accused of striking yolanda hadid
the mother of his girlfriend gigi here's
what we know a source tells e.t the two
had a disagreement that turned hostile
yolanda is telling people around her
that zane struck her yolanda is
extremely upset and it has caused issues
with zane and gigi the source adds that
gigi was not there when the alleged
incident transpired and she's had to
listen to both sides of the story a rep
for gigi tells et gigi is solely focused
on the best for kai she asks for privacy
during this time et has reached out to
yolanda and zane's reps for comment
zane shared his reaction after tmz broke
the story on thursday posting this
lengthy message to twitter as you all
know i am a private person and i very
much want to create a safe and private
space for my daughter to grow up in a
place where private family matters
aren't thrown on the world stage for all
to poke and pick apart in an effort to
protect that space for her i agreed to
not contest claims arising from an
argument i had with a family member of
my partners who entered our home while
my partner was away several weeks ago
zayn goes on to blast the alleged
incident becoming public which he said
has interfered with parenting
one-year-old daughter kai
this was and still should be a private
matter but it seems for now there is
divisiveness and despite my efforts to
restore us to a peaceful family
environment that will allow for me to
co-parent my daughter in a manner in
which she deserves this has been leaked
to the press zane ended that statement
by saying he hopes that there will be
healing for all involved despite some
apparently harsh words he claims were
shared after his social post zane
released another statement to tmz saying
he adamantly denies striking yolanda
adding quote for the sake of my daughter
i declined to give any further details
and i hope that yolanda will reconsider
her false allegations and move towards
healing these family issues in private
what did he transform into
zane and gigi have been together for
years starting in 2015. he's obviously
so gorgeous but
really the way that we could have
conversations and kind of just
were really interested in the same
things and it was really easy so that
was amazing the two took at least one
extended break from one another but in
early 2020 gigi confirmed she and the
former one directioner were back
together by announcing they were
expecting their first child together on
the tonight show we're very excited and
happy and grateful for everyone's well
wishes and support so she also revealed
she and zane have been quarantining with
gigi's family and like especially during
this time it's nice
it's a nice silver lining to be able to
like be home and together and like
really
experience it day by day so the pair
welcomed baby kai later that same year
and last month yolanda shared a birthday
tribute for her granddaughter she wrote
in part no words can express how much
love and joy you have brought into our
lives adding quote thank you to your
incredible mama gigi and bubba zane for
the greatest gift of life and back in
2017 yolanda praised her eldest
daughter's partner while speaking to e.t
he's just a really good person you know
he comes from very humble beginnings so
he's just a normal guy and he's a good
human being
you